it just came out
like
a month ago or a couple months ago
and that really kind of brought it up to
the next level
first off can you clarify led walls
versus green screen
led wall is
an actual
like led panel so you're like a tv
screen think of a tv screen
so the image is on the screen right but
the green screen is just a green
paint
um
and what so with the green screen you're
doing vfx
after you filmed
then you're putting something to replace
that green but with the led wall you're
filming everything in camera so whatever
you film you're taking that footage and
that's your final um
you know picture
which do you prefer using
um
led wall but i haven't done it yet
but i think i would like it because
there's a lot of benefits to led wall if
you can
get the wall because it's quite
expensive compared to green screen
but if you can get the led wall what
you're getting is
you have the light coming from the
actual led wall itself which gives it
much more of a realistic lighting effect
with green screen you have to put a
light over there and like recreate the
light that would be coming from that
direction
another thing is like reflections so
with the green screen you're not going
to get that but with led wall you can
see reflections of whatever image
scenery
so that creates another more realistic
image but also for actors they're now
immersed in
the environment so they can act as if
they're actually you know wherever
whereas with green screen you know it's
harder for an actor
and so with a green screen a lot of
that's done on the timeline the editing
timeline you're you're adding the yeah
afterwards post production you're going
to add that the effects in there
but with led as a director too you can
already see exactly what this is going
to look like
you know you don't need the visual
effects artist to tell you like oh see
this image we're going to put this there
and then we're going to put this thing
there
you know you can see exactly what that's
going to look like along with the
lighting and everything
how many virtual production studios have
you visited i've visited
maybe
three
yeah three studios
yeah so not that many
here in the la area or something there's
there's a lot in um in la
i think we have the most in the world
right now
don't quote me on that okay all right
and what is unreal engine unreal engine
is
a game engine that was created by epic
games
originally for video games you know to
create video games but now
in recent years they've started using it
for film and tv
because the um
the 3d rendering
has caught on
to be very photorealistic but at the
same time you could do it in real time
like you can move things around and
change lighting in real time instead of
having to wait for a render which you
know back in the days would take
you know many hours or days
to render out like a sequence
have you used unreal engine with any of
your productions
um so
for my new project killing of a machine
this is the first time i'm using
unreal engine for a project
but i did spend about eight months
learning unreal engine with um a school
called
um cgpro
and yeah they've been great the main
instructor there ed
dawson he was the bfx supervisor for the
lion king and the jungle book
and yeah through them as well as other
like online tutorials and resources i
was able to learn how to use the
software
and i created my my own environment my
own level
and that's where my story takes place
and so did you take classes at an actual
classroom or this was all online oh it's
all virtual all virtual okay
and and so do you have to have a special
computer just for that is it taking up
too much
yeah you do need a very powerful
computer
pc
you know get a pc
and the graphics card needs to be pretty
powerful
and yeah i mean i don't know that much
about computers so i i basically went to
this custom computer company um puget
systems and i was like i need something
for unreal engine just whatever you guys
build
just make sure it works for that program
and they were able to create a really
powerful system
and so is it like a regular timeline
like final cut pro or adobe and but it's
it's
different because um it's different
interfaces there's a lot more going on
but
similar there is a timeline aspect to it
but there's much more to the software
because you're
dealing with 3d objects
so you're dropping 3d objects in and you
know moving things around
but there is a timeline aspect as well
and are you saving these projects on the
computer or in the cloud
on the computer
okay so you have to have a lot of space
it sounds like do these projects wow
yeah so you said it was a nine month
course
um no i i've just been doing my own
studying for about nine months but
for this class it was only a two month
course
and so with your short film you're going
to do the entire film with unreal engine
is that right
so you can do a animation with
everything in unreal so that would just
be like a cgi movie but for mine i'm
creating the background and the world in
unreal engine but i'm going to be
filming it on a actual led volume with
live actors
so you put the live actor in a costume
in front of the wall but on the wall
it's going to be the actual environment
that i've created
and you show some of that on your
youtube channel correct a little bit of
yeah a little bit my earlier prototype
kind of design
but now my previz is a lot better
and that's what's great about unreal
engine even if you're not filming
something you know on an led wall for a
filmmaker you can create previz within
the engine and you know bring in like
actors um mannequins
and and plan out your shots
so that when you get on set you already
can see exactly what your film is going
to look like you know because a lot of
indie filmmakers especially
you know
you don't have the luxury of getting on
set and going oh let's try that shot or
let's try this oh you know what move
that light over there let's try a
different thing you have to just go go
go
but if you try out all your you know
variations beforehand then when you get
on set you're you already know like
which shot looks cool um
how to do the sequence
so it gives you much more
planning and control
so you're using you're going to use sort
of a manipulated background with the led
panel but then live actors
who will be there at the same time that
you're filming
yeah from mine yep interesting wow
and then the led panel is it like
many many feet or is it several panels
put together
um it's a huge panel or a huge wall so
they come in different sizes but each
panel is like
you know like a square piece
so but they'll put all these little
panels together
um the wall is pretty huge
i don't know exactly how tall
probably
20 yeah 15 feet
kind of thing
so you have to book time to to you have
to block it out and have a production
schedule in order to use the
yeah it's kind of like any stage you
would just book it by a day
yeah it's like a day rate
wow that's really cool how much has this
changed your life this unreal engine and
this virtual production
oh
it definitely changed it in a different
direction um a much more exciting
direction
i mean i pretty much once i found out
about it i was like okay i gotta learn
this so i mean i dumped all my money
into the computer and taking classes
and
but it
gave me
a new outlook in terms of how i can tell
my stories because for example this
short film i wrote this script maybe
like two years ago
and
thinking i'll never be able to make it
because
you know it takes place in the arctic
and you know their spaceships and
whatever and you know the effects itself
would cost so much money
but now i can make it because i learned
how to do the vfx myself and it really
wasn't that difficult to learn
and that's what's so great about unreal
engine is like you don't really need to
be like a vfx artist to understand how
to use it because a lot of the assets
are pre-created already so you're just
pulling in assets and like customizing
it and changing it and then you already
have your world you're not really
building it from scratch
is it compatible with a mac
yeah you can use it with mac but we
most people don't recommend doing that
because there's some things with mac
that i guess it can't really process
i'm not 100 sure how that works but um
yeah a lot of people have some issues
with macs
i ask what does it cost to use this
technology well
the software itself is free
um you just have to
have a really sick computer
yeah i think that's probably the biggest
barrier is the computer my computer cost
almost four thousand
but um to rent the led stages they're
quite expensive right now but they're
starting to come down
and you can
maybe find a smaller stage that maybe
has a smaller led panel and you could do
a hybrid you can shoot some green screen
like the wide shots and then go to the
led for your medium and close shots so
there's always ways to you know work
around it and depending on your budget
you can probably negotiate with some of
the studios as well because right now
it's so new that a lot of these studios
they want to make content to show other
filmmakers
hey you can do this like this is what it
looks like because a lot of people don't
really know about this yet they still
think like oh
it's going to look fake or something but
if the studios can prove
that on an indie budget you can make
something realistic
that would get more business for them so
they're actually willing to you know
really negotiate and work with you um if
you have a cool project
if you were to use unreal engine let's
say for las vegas scenes let's suppose
there were scenes that you just really
couldn't get you needed a certain kind
of permits or it wouldn't be safe would
you actually film the background and
then upload that to unreal engine and
then have that
as part of the led panel or you're
creating it
graphically
i think i would probably create it
yeah because you can already
get pre-existing
like
perfectly modeled um vegas scenes
and you would just
drop it into your level and move things
around a little bit change the lighting
and then just have that there
yeah because if you go and film
then you don't have the dynamic ability
to move
the angles
you know or unless you would have to
film every single angle like that just
wouldn't um wouldn't be practical
but if you have the environment you can
go in that scene and get any angle you
want
put the actor anywhere you want change
the lighting however you want you can
even change
um what's in the background move things
around
so it kind of has its own templates for
different you know whether you're in
france or vegas or i know you had one
where you were in the forest i think
yeah yeah channel that looked really
so on um epic games they have a
marketplace where they have a lot of
these levels and things are already
pre-made
and there's people making their own
assets and just you know selling them
i mean a lot of it is for free actually
on um quicksole you can download all
these like
really high
detailed um 3d assets for free
but there's also people who are selling
them for like you know 20 bucks 30 bucks
kind of stuff
so people you said make their own
assets their own graphics whatever
interesting that's fascinating
do you think it's affordable for most
independent filmmakers
um i think right now
there's a little bit of a barrier
because of the computer issue
but
i think it's going to change you know
and as the led panels get cheaper
you're going to see the studio rates go
down lower as well
so
it's definitely
affordable for indie filmmakers
and you know
there's different levels of it as well
there's people using a projector like a
home projector
to do the same type of um workflow
or you can even use a tv
like it's pretty interesting what some
of these people are doing like if you go
on youtube you'll see people doing their
own like
hacks of um
how they can do it uh like in their home
studio like they can do it
yeah
interesting so they have their own let's
say big screen tv and they have some
type of image in the background
wouldn't it reflect wouldn't wouldn't
you see
certain um are there ways around that
where you know
you just have to get the lighting right
like the lighting that's on the tv
um
but yeah there's ways to do it i've seen
it with the projector it actually looked
pretty good
how soon do you think you'll see
youtubers vloggers with this technology
in their bedrooms
and they're they're vlogging and
you know they're somewhere in the sahara
desert
um i think there's already people doing
that
so it's already here
this technology
has only been used for last three years
but with unreal engine 5 it just came
out
like
a month ago or a couple months ago
and that really kind of brought it up to
the next level um there's a few features
in there where
just like the realism of the the
characters
it's next level
and there's a thing called meta humans
and now they just release this thing
where you can scan
anything
but probably you want to scan your own
face
and make yourself into a meta-human
the meta-human just means that it has a
complex skeleton system
and they have a bunch of pre-made
character faces that you can manipulate
but now you can bring in your own assets
and make it into a metahuman wow so
we're definitely going to be seeing a
lot of very interesting things
soon
yeah what if you're sleeping and the
meta human comes out of your pc
there's a movie and attacks you yeah and
there you go